hello they also shitty allenbury is
Harrison so good God only already step
out like I got liking I want me and
Jimmy are old pals and we had to get
dirty for a few minutes yeah we are
welcome to and you guys are promoting by
the way glow we haven't mentioned
available on Netflix this Friday and
it's really good it is good really well
yeah especially because you know like a
I'm a big wrestling fan and a lot of the
yeah a lot of wrestling fans are excited
about it but they're also like you know
if you don't do wrestling right well
don't then the wrestling fans get very
very upset well we were a little nervous
about that ourselves but we trained with
Chavo Guerrero jr. who is and has is
from a wrestling legacy you know yeah
yeah yeah it's major so he was a real
obviously the expert on everything and
taught us the moves and nomenclature and
really also when we would bring in moves
and be like look at this cool move let's
do that he be like no that move was not
invented till 1994 that's great we can't
do that on this because I was watching
because when he did like a top rope
thing with it I was like oh this is
where I'm gonna be out because I'm gonna
know but it was that it wasn't like a 90
top rope thing it was an 80 welcome out
thing and I was like yeah toggle the
best it was really good and Chavez uncle
mando Guerrero trained the original
women of glove right that's like a cool
connection
nice fancy you heard it I'll do it no no
because they were really good about
safety with us and we also had a stunt
coordinator Shana Duggan's who was there
throughout all our training and every
day of shooting and her main job was to
sort of break down the moves for us and
like help us to be able to do them for
hours on end you learn but you did learn
how to bump oh yeah it's we all were all
we did was bump all day every day run
bomb package yeah that's it because I
read that there you use stunt doubles we
guys watching take like prop bumps and
like no oh yeah yeah a front bump is
just basically slamming your full body
face down onto the mat and a back and a
back bump is slamming on your back yeah
how do you do that without slamming your
face and hurting
well you sort of more land on your chest
and your arms are at at the same time
it's more it's all about like you know
dispersing your weight everything's
hitting at the same time it's like your
thighs are taking more of it even though
you're all landing on ones and on your
back it's the same where it's like flat
back chin tucked your whole back hips at
the same time your arms hit at the same
time so you're sort of like helping
right you know pushing yourself off so
funnier like that anymore
yes weird that I'm a weird authority on
the job I'm not not tuck your chin in
the beginning because if you don't tuck
your chin you're doing a bomb yeah your
head snaps back and you ever try any of
the moves no I mean I'm like I've gotten
in the ring for like you know a minute
or two though teeth like a an indie
promotion would teach me how to do one
thing like a little spot right and then
I would just run away or something
it was wild to uh to watch them all do
it you know like I'm the only guy really
for the most part you don't do any
wrestling I do any wrestling but here's
the thing is like I got the part
it was sort of a fluke in a way like I
finished Maren and then at you know I
got sent this script for this guy you
know this kind of like you know down and
out
film director dude with a cocaine
problem and divorces and I'm like I
could be this guy now and I'd really get
you know opportunity to audition for
anything but I was like I'm going to do
it I went down to the eyeglasses place
where I know the ladies I got some
aviator frames I put on a Lacoste shirt
I had my little personal trainer woman
who's also an actress we'd Allison's
part I had a hard time assistant shooter
on the iPhone because they weren't
looking at people in LA you can either
tape in and I got it off of that Wow Wow
off the tape yeah and when they told me
that the guy knows nothing about
wrestling I'm like great I'm not going
to do any research at all yeah so all I
knew and I'll tell you the story because
it's funny it is like I knew who this go
I wanted this guy to be I knew we needed
aviator glasses
what are any other glasses we are just
the Ray Ban style you know the 20 aisle
the frames in the kind of the kind of
timeless you know dude but
show the same picture it's up a little
more there was one of there was no go
down it was me and Stanley next to me go
down go down I thought I saw one
yeah saw one yeah but oh there it is on
the right there with a cigarette down
the lower right yeah there you go okay
and that's me oh yeah those are aviators
but see like I knew the guys they told
me I guess my it was a great they told
me I could smoke so I knew I needed a
flip-top box yeah the guy had a cocaine
problem so I told you that women who
created the show Carly and Liz are like
complete nerds you know and they're in
the mid-30s but they're nerdy women they
know that I'm not saying anything mean
so I went up to him and I said look
right this guy with the coke he doesn't
share it doesn't deal with vials he only
deals with bindles like squares cut from
magazines and when he does it he does it
with a key or a pen time and they're
both looking at me and one says Carly
says we're so glad you're here
well I knew exactly what I was Marcus
the authority on cocaine usage a
cigarette that's why there's no smoke
around you start for this no those are
fake cigarettes and because of the loss
engines which I'm still hopelessly
addicted to even when I smoke those I
don't ever feel like going back Liz it's
weird it's like herbal in those it
doesn't really it's the same it's weird
and it doesn't burn the same and it
smells but it does give you a little
head thing it may it started to bother
me this is my thing we shot in a car
yeah I was midway through a cigarette
you never end you started seeing midway
into a cigarette and then you got doom a
bunch of cake so you got to pump it down
and by the way my character who does not
smoke at all
mark and I campaigned to have me take a
puff of his cigarette in the scene and
we really sold it to the director and
our writers and losing Carly Nevins like
alright yeah do that in the scene and
then of course yeah an hour into
shooting the scene oh that's why smoking
cigarettes we're all staying in that car
I don't have to take cigarettes that's
how stupid I am so these are not real
nicotine cigarettes no they're all there
you they don't they don't have a real
effect but maybe magic okay
but you knew inhaling
more question I'm like what do you so
what are you inhaling I don't know a big
mystery you don't know what talking
about tobacco like a grinder like you
like totally stoned all the time
could you imagine people on Mad Men
where they just lie you're great on Mad
Men thank you again my character didn't
smoke I think that the Campbells were
the only people who didn't smoke and it
was I was very thankful yeah yeah lean
home yeah yeah did you like playing
something that's kind of falling apart
on this show yeah yeah except you don't
get to do that that much no I don't I
play people that are very put together
and I did I like that Ruth is not a
perfect person and I like that she makes
like a very big mistake in the first
episode and that sometimes she's a
difficult person to root for but
ultimately I hope your people do he's
genius what's wrong room what's with the
playing up to play earnestness ambition
desperation and still we had our man
right like I watched her every day I'm
like oh my god yeah this is a
complicated character and you want to
not like her but she's so amazing you
can't not like her I like it when Mark
talks about the character I like it very
good I can people misunderstand our
dynamic like because it like yeah seeing
some people write about the first five
episodes room just as cantankerous
abusive guy but for me like and I'm very
grating and I'm like well but right here
is her right I give you a hard time I'm
like these guys love each other
definitely like other people
misconstrued as romantic we don't think
it ever another kindred spirits
yeah they do sort of that also get more
insulating the season too because that
doesn't start to develop in the first
you know episode six yeah it really yeah
I do think they drive each other a lot
as characters they do have a common goal
which is like they both want this show
to be a success more than anyone maybe
once I realized what it is yeah yeah I
choked up all the time it just really it
was ridiculous Wow like it's just like
there were there were scenes where I'm
doing this guy and I'm I'm showing up
emotionally for her character and I'm
not a professional actor so I really
show it up and like I feel like you
time for crying mark it looks like a rob
ball of emotion I am sometimes I did
reading the reviews why get sent to me
I'm going really good I've read some of
them yeah cause I'm like I don't read
reviews and I don't care about reviews
oh the reviews are good funny how nobody
during is good reviews critics don't
know what they're talking yeah people
yeah thority on eww I would check them
out are you guys playing real people I
know the situation is real but are you
actually playing a real no and it's
important to note that because none of
the lives of these characters are real
they're all fictitious so it's more just
taken off of the premise of Glo and
there are real things about it the fact
that the women who auditioned for Glo
the women wrestlers who were on Glo were
not wrestlers they were similar to us
they were actresses who were just at
different places in their life an
audition for this random wrestling
television show and then they had very
intense training with mando Guerrero was
like well there's stories about him
putting one of the girls in a sleeper
hold day one until she passed out on the
mat just to like prove a point yeah
that's a serious method also in the 80s
when like wrestling was still protected
so what you didn't have these actresses
coming in and thinking that they could
just play wrestle toe-to-toe mondo would
oh he knocked one of them unconscious
with a sleeper hold so that all the
other girls in Rio Lyle this is what
yeah in the real government oh
definitely and then they I mean you
watch these women and they go for it on
the real Glo and there's a documentary
about the women's of the women of glow
that's on Netflix now and they talk
about their like we were getting hurt
there was there were a lot of them are
like we never quite figured out how to
do it and not get hurt and that's
something actually that even with us
there were points where you're doing the
backlinks and even you'd nail it you'd
have your chin perfectly tucked and
Chavo would be like yes it's just like
that you'd be like I mean it kind of
hurt can he be like oh yeah it's gonna
hurt yeah hitting the matter as long as
it's hurting in this way and not in a
bad way and you're like oh okay yeah
yeah I didn't do any like I know there
was like the the documentary and stuff
and I knew that this was completely
fictionalized and one of the reasons I
didn't watch it because I know that
there was a character in that or
couple of guys in the original that
might've inspired my character but I'm
like why do that to myself like just you
know build this guy from the ground up
if it's a fictional character yeah and
not you know the fact that I like I said
I didn't need to know about wrestling's
a character I'm like I just got to do
what my instincts tell me to do I didn't
want to put it in my head I agree I
watched the documentary which was
actually really interesting just to hear
all the women talk about their
experience of working on glow and just
so I could get more of an idea of what a
hit it was like how quickly it laid with
so many people but similarly then I did
sort of distance myself none of us we
get asked a lot if we were like meeting
with the original cast of glow and
they've been very supportive of our show
but we really weren't because I think we
didn't want to be stealing explicit
details from their lives right Ruth is
her own character we're not trying to
imply that any of the women on that show
you know what with a married guy or did
I need stuff like that so you wanted to
kind of create your own person spoiler
alert definitely worth seeing was a
great scene thank you really [ __ ]
sexiness I've never got a praise I like
that I like that it seems like this show
orange is a new blank as well it's these
female ensemble shows that are obviously
telling female stories but then they'll
throw nudity in as well so in
psychiatric guys into watching me being
like yes a good start right yeah he has
sort of talked about that the nudity and
like our bodies and and that sort of
exploitation as being sort of the Trojan
horse of this show we were like
smuggling in real intimate stories about
women's lives under the guise of like
tits and ass I had a sign the nudity
thing like you know and I knew that if
like after what she did like I had to be
willing to be naked and everyone on the
show had to be willy yeah and like I was
like I can't we're gonna I really have
this thing which like why it's only fair
you know but when it came down to the
new tune I'm like can we go no [ __ ]
could we not do the cover guy you know
I don't did you not do it huh they
should do they out of your question oh
yeah there's a shot but I did have to
walk around the show a fat dumb
[ __ ] oxide you know an optional or
do they I imagine it's optional but like
if you could just show us play I don't
like you two it's a weird dumb thing but
I do yeah I was worried about my ass I
took selfies of my ass yeah to make sure
it looked all right before I did the ass
shot like anyways I ruined our my new
push-ups aggressions
I just want temples or anything on my
butt yeah makeup on my knees and a snake
ephedrine that's when you lose the
essence of the character because your
character would probably not have the
greatest ass in the world at that point
a tec-9 I didn't do any work on my ass I
just want to make sure that like once it
does hit the internet there's not people
zooming in is like it yeah we're on at
this point in our career if you're
taking your clothes off it's for a joke
I do like the way they use nudity in
this show and on orange is the new black
it's sort of women taking ownership
again of that nudity and not doing it in
a way that like you sort of catch people
in nude moments or changing their
clothes or whatever and it's not sort of
like I look sexual and perfect in this
moment of being naked yeah more sort of
just realistic
nudity yeah which I like like a person's
changing their shirt and then you see
their tits it's not sort of like who
changes their shirt is like just right
so I got into a debate with my niece oh
no wonder
[Laughter]
grace no this testimony begins about
Wonder Woman like she was also like to
be empowered by it and but then she was
questioning like why is she still in
that costume let's see I think that that
is the whole point it's like a feminist
doesn't women can be sexy and be
empowered at the same time yeah and
she's such a strong woman and it's an
iconic Wonder Woman a uniformed cop yeah
man wears spandex yeah we always think
we don't want to [ __ ] hone in the
Barbarian
so they're all good-looking well-built
people that's what they do it can be
both and that she's owning it and it's
not really done for men she's not
wearing that outfit and you're seeing
guys aughh alarm or like looking at her
in awe of her strength and she happens
to be wearing that outfit I feel like
that's like a number one thing is why a
percentage of men like job I care how
strong shut it off yeah Eleanor laughs
okay were you worried at all that the
show would get cheesy because there's
been very little done saved for maybe
the movie the wrestler any movie or TV
show that centers around Pro Wrestling
has been like historically the cheesiest
like the weird thing was is that they
handled the period so meticulously and
without cam penis or irony right like
there was no one waving around a giant
phone like this right it was like it was
just infused throughout and in the
outfits like I was alive and a grown
person in 1986 yeah I wasn't running out
with people that dressed like these
women did right but I knew it was there
like there was no it was almost like
time travel for me we didn't seem that
Outland right and I think that because
they were all so earnest about the
endeavor that you did it doesn't come
off as cheesy it comes off as very
intense very powerful and it was all
like on the nose 80s even some of your
wardrobe is still like still holding on
to the 70s I feel like there's a great
group of looks so you're not just like
me on a Madonna bracelet oh I dropped my
way mcd these guys ever all right he has
winked at the camera that horrible no I
think also just hearing that Genji Cohen
was behind it I wasn't super familiar
with Liz and Hartley's work when I first
got the script but hearing that Genji
was doing it I was already like oh this
will be kind of gritty and cool and then
reading the very first episode to hell
in the writing yeah how did you do it I
do want I opposite of mark I got the
script and heard about the idea and just
became singularly obsessed with doing it
and then heard that they didn't think I
was right for it at all and didn't
really want to see me for the rollout
and
my agents just called and hounded them
and finally I went in I knew the casting
director Jen euston she had cast a film
that I had done and so she brought me in
and put me on tape and then I came in
again for producers then I came in again
and read with Betty then I came in again
and read again with Betty and I won them
[ __ ] oh that always amazing people who
they don't think are right for it that
like no no I want to do this like I
admire that [ __ ] man I'm potentially
you wanted it it's currently not getting
angry because you've done so much stuff
and everybody knows you're great and
then to be like humble enough to go
through that private part of it was them
sort of testing me and being like well
we wanted sort of maybe someone the face
that people haven't really seen and
they're familiar with me playing
characters that are so polished and
something that I do think was like I
mean sure if she wants to go on tape for
casting and I was like damn right I'm
going on I'm going on forever so you're
not much different than you are in the
in that opening here was just being yeah
I think that my own desperation was
coming through the more auditions that
they just couldn't unsee it they were
like she knew the character right I got
you I can't believe you I can't believe
you're doing glow and the disaster
artist in the same year because it's
those are probably my two favorite
things good wrestling in the room you
know yeah yeah I'll be I'll be on board
with your projects going forward yeah
yeah are you excited about the disaster
artist is the movie about the making of
the room Tommy Wiseau's masterpiece
are you a masterpiece yeah
are you excited about yeah will be
coming out definitely know what to ask
about I mean were you I'm assuming you
were a big fan of the room before no not
at all man yeah I remembered I had never
seen the room but I remembered those
billboards of time with those face
lessons that were up all over Los
Angeles and like haunting my dreams and
you know I but I'd never saw the movie
and then my husband Dave who stars in
the movie he had been doing research for
months and read the book the disaster
artist which the movie is based on
written by Greg Sestero who's the other
lead actor in the room of course and
it's all about his experience meeting
Tommy and there
friendship is a really sweet kind of odd
success story yeah anyway we'd like
listen to the book on tape before I had
ever seen the room I heard the whole
behind-the-scenes stories and like
learned all about this guy Tommy Wiseau
and then which I said from for a long
time the book I usually do book on tape
but that book on tape is the best
because Greg Sestero does the best Tommy
was so impressed an amazing
Tommy impression so this is like all I
knew about Tommy was Greg Sestero Tommy
and then Davey was like you gotta watch
the movie so we bought it and we watched
it at home in like five minutes and I'm
like I gotta have a drink or we hate or
something like I can't watch this
totally sober but it's kind of an
amazing movie yes it may feel the acting
was a bit lackluster and Jimmy not just
not up to snuff right right
thank done so in earnest yeah oh yeah
passion and you're just like what is
happening and James Franco please tell
me or so and directed it right and that
was very bizarre dating character the
whole time yes
so he's directing uni as it's like
vaguely Eastern European accent and like
long hair and facial prosthetics on
shoes it was strange yeah like that was
sorry so he does a movie typically where
his you like method will stay in or did
he do fit like a wine that will Express
I don't know I feel like Tommy the
character is such an overpowering
presence and the accent is so strange I
understand why you would want to stay in
it I'm a guy who played in that Harmony
Korine movie what was remember that
Spring Breakers yes man was like an
alien yes he had me I love that movie
movie I'm going to his hair like that I
think you did right warmer oh yeah I had
a Anna Stan character they're not okay I
have to say I'm a haircut and permed for
this show and I was just living in 1985
like three half months that we had it I
mean I created my jeans
why didn't they just the ones that you
were just wear off set like we're not
zombies
are you like my own G no winter was a
nice written character right really the
same pair of pain I was saying pants the
entire shoot me too and there's these
like mom jeans he's like waist don't
watch this you walk around I didn't
learn until we started doing press for
the show how much mark hated I don't
know buddy maybe they might a few hey
you've just been like how would anyone
getting laid in the eighties wearing
jeans fantasize about you when you're in
those that's my character not real mark
I was going to tell you yeah I had a I
had Tommy was so up here and interviewed
him for like an hour
oh my god and I know that you find his
accent to be Eastern European but he
informed me he's just gets he's from New
Orleans that's right he's right you
married yes he sounds like it's the
weirdest thing
being from New Orleans yeah it's strange
yeah it's like Asian accent that's what
he's guys that's all it is and so to put
on European accent no it's pretending to
be a Mary I might be I believe he's
contending that he's American casillas
his old but he funded his movie through
his business which was called street
fashions USA that's a very mysterious
character nobody knows his aid no nobody
knows his place of origin it's like
right how many people Carius yeah make
up only about it we made a movie about
it I hope you like kerosene I know all
about the room but never watched it I've
never seen anything I want I can get in
a theater oh my god I didn't need to see
it in a theater though yeah you got it
just imagine it's just like a strangest
collection of scenes there's no rhyme or
reason there's men in tuxedos throwing a
football around on a rooftop like and
I've seen that scene I felt the football
is out of place yeah I did it was a
little out of place
yeah UI questions with some of the
choices yeah some of you - Tiffany I'm
still is there 15 choices right I
understand I understand um mark do you
think you're gonna do more acting now
because everybody's whatever sticking
out both of you on this show
oh uh uh but like I think what I always
wanted to do is one of the things where
you know I did I think I figured out how
to do it in a
basically doing my show for fourth
season right I I want to do more but I
don't want to you know I'm not going to
be learning Russian accents or anything
like if it's in my wheel I like this guy
Sam the reason I wanted to do him so
badly is that I could identify with the
character but he is different than me in
that he's not neurotic in any way he
doesn't you know he doesn't he's not
self analytical so it was almost like a
relief I'm like I can just shut that
[ __ ] off and just be sort of an
unashamed you [ __ ] struggling yeah
yeah you know and and haphazardly
becoming a better person so yeah I'd
like to do more acting I'd like to
challenge myself like if we do another
season is I keep thinking about it
because I haven't studied acting that
much but like I did interview Martin
Landau in my last year on the podcast
I've done some interviews with actors
and now I really get into like tips and
what I like hearing that
yet I've talked to like acting with them
as actors right yeah might give me some
more like can you help me out because I
got a thing so I think if I do another
season I do want to challenge myself
somehow and just like you know the craft
of it or however I can wrap my brain
around doing things that you know would
make me better at it it's an amazing
thing about your podcast though that you
can yeah for sure that you can get these
people in and just kind of that you
would never get to talk to and then ask
them for advice on whatever [ __ ] that
you need whatever you got going on I do
that was the reason I did the podcast is
do idea is just to have so ever hear
over to help me with my problem that's
always got my style